close your eyes and then we're going to
bring your blind date
out okay open your
eyes hello hi I'm Stephen I'm Julia nice
meet you
hi what come on do it do it come on do
it yeah yeah that was a yes do it
hi that's what
I say yes I said yes I got too many
girlfriends to not
know
hi the tilt of the head how you doing
good how are you pretty high pretty high
was a little nervous so yeah I'm not
going to lie the girls are way better
looking than dudes is a different they
brought some too crusty looking Ted up
pierced up Dopey looking dudes and they
brought girls who came out with their
finest yep sorry me too
[__] what are you drinking the
whiskey me
too why are you single what's wrong with
you um I've just been like taking time
to like you know take
my time um oh my God I'm like so nervous
this is should we like meditate for a
about like let just take a breath let's
regulat her it's over it's off it's off
first for first of all the girl with the
short hair play you know what the [__]
you doing player you know what the hell
you doing player player cuz cuz the
looks of what you said first later when
you said player player and what is wrong
with you the way you when you looked at
her you know what that meant and man oo
there is nothing wrong with you baby
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
you and why would you ask that question
to her that was first second whenever
she said that and she felt nervous you
SLI lit in oh I'mma make you feel
comfortable baby girl yeah give me in
let's meditate Let's YO this girl I'm
telling you right now when they initiate
touch and the person willingly accepts
right away it's done donezo why are you
single what's wrong with you I just you
know like my peace like being alone a
lot I do like being alone as well I'm
more of a giver and love her and
sometimes people take that like like for
granted and then they bro get that soup
out your the [__] out of y y frog ass
get the soup out your mouth it sounds
stupid but that's the only I can think
of I uh am single because I feel like
I'm a pushover I become less of me and
more who that person wants me to be
apparently somebody wanted you to be a
[Music]
Kardashian sorry violently correct sir
my biggest ick is like girls that are
like very act kind of entitled you're
talking to someone and then like they
won't respond you text or then they post
on Instagram on day oh I do
that I
listen I'm not mad at her if I'm not
interested in somebody I'm like yeah I
did that uh you know I'm not into I'm
not into to to to men who who beat their
girls I yeah I did I do that all the
time
absolutely I'm not into man who uh just
stick fingers in their girls bum without
could I do that love it I got doooo St
right now I do that what else don't you
like don't worry about it before you
even say it I do it I've never done it
before but I'll start doing if we date
just leave me alone what do you find
most attractive about me
physically you're just like really
pretty like like you're very symmetrical
and very yeah you are you are you think
so girl you haven't seen my titties like
they
are like Israel and Palestine that
border keep shifting you know what I'm
saying like there's settlements being
built here and then
this cancer
the region does have
cancer you have really good eyes too
they're just really small I don't know
people always tell me how small they are
like no they're cute it's like a cute
smirk you like talk a lot with them good
I like that
yeah where did that come from yeah
listen I agree [__] no that's the
second time he did that oh oh you think
I'm I'm very manly thank you
[__] I up three do you have any kinks
King like somebody's hands could just
turn me on just let's see your hands my
hands are are dry and like not no
they're not so no they're not touch me
no they're not give me your hand so I
can feel them no they're not you're
insecure about them rubbing on my face
that's why I appreciate you short hair
lady yeah I appreciate you yeah she got
game I'm not going to she got game no
you have nice hands you have real nice
hands yes you know so funny though
sometimes you be compliment on women
before you even seen it you just be like
you have really nice hands you your
you're like what the [__] are these
crusty nails but you're too far gone so
yeah your your nails are gr oh my God
your hands are beautiful welcome to the
Crusty Crab like [__] like
that I have definitely tried to compl no
cuz our nails are not that Port but
sometimes L got busted nails like it's
just like half chipped three like do
something just scrape it off jeez I
ain't asking for much ooh
sorry between us who do you think would
be more dominant in the bedroom short
hair I feel you'll be you for
sure do you think for sure for sure she
look like she got a bunch of strapons at
home different sizes different things
who do you think would be more dominant
in the bedroom probably
me
H but no no no no no ABA ABA ABA ABA ABA
I get it cuz how is he going to be
dominant in the bedroom yeah yeah that's
nice you like that
mhm yeah I feel for her man I I get it
like yeah she got set up with looking
loser that hand is not
good oh
God have you ever ate ass yes yes yes
yes
yes yes yes when hasn't she eating ass
that's the real question my girl she's
eating ass right now and you feel it yes
I feel we should just take a shot to
take a yeah cheers to that cheers to
eating ass like I'm not just eating ass
the first time I I need to know your ass
before I eat it I need to like yeah just
to eating ass I need to know your ass
before yes IM girl just bent over a
doggy side you just sitting right y so
who is you where you been at what's your
name who you been letting out of you
where you from how big have you ever ate
ass yes yes no that's a l cap C no this
is 2023 if you haven't ate ass yet have
you ever ate ass yes okay I'm taking a
shot okay bro you sound like you do lean
every weekend okay yes you being an ass
you you eat anything that anyone put in
front of you my friend sounds like
you I don't know how they got too Dopey
looking these are the two most Dopey
people I've ever seen on the cut ever
and they were both in the same episode
it is crazy what's your type am I your
type I would I would say like yeah
really she tried to play it but I fail
so I mean I would yeah I've been in love
before and um sometimes you fall out of
love sometimes that you can be in love
with someone but not still love them and
you kind of started seeing them more as
was like a best friend other than a
lover MH because all out of love you
love them but you're not in love with
them yeah exactly I have been in love
but the love ended because we wanted
different things that makes sense
mhm yeah yeah we fell out of love cuz we
wanted different things um she wanted to
just [__] me and I wanted to [__]
everyone else and we fell
out sorry sometimes people say stuff we
wanted different things I just be asking
like what like what uh she wanted SCD
free life and I like to roll the
dice it's single and then you like find
yourself again you know yeah it's like a
rebirth for sure it takes part of you
when it's gone of course that was so
deep holy [__] have you ever cheated not
going to lie when I was with my ex I
didn't realize it but I was think I was
cheating the whole time I had like a big
laugh and I would do photo shoot and
sometimes like I probably forget I have
a girlfriend and then we'll hook up and
then it's like you would forget you have
a
girlfriend hey
yo some of you [__] is
trash the audacity I sometimes forget I
have a partner
what what I have never heard that I have
I've heard a lot I've watched a million
plus videos I have never heard I forget
I have a partner no let me tell you why
though she was kind of like seeing her
ex the whole time it was like an open
relationship sometime we have like a
break and then like so it's like friends
we were on a
break yeah I have no no no no no no not
I forgot that I had a girlfriend and
what what do you mean like that's that's
what no it was an open relationship then
it wouldn't have mattered sounds like it
what isn't what you're saying cap sounds
like you cap that's like you cap you're
so high that cap is real shut up rate
your oral skills from 1 to 10 20
20 okay 25 50 I feel like every man says
that but they don't no I give myself
like a
five five but I make up for it in
cuddles and kisses so you know what I
mean you know what you're bargaining for
you can't fail and I tell guys is all
the time yo set the [__] bar low some
of you guys out here are overrating your
[__] I I know what I'm good at but
you also better know what you're bad at
cuz you can't be good at everything just
be honest it's fine but you be out here
lying to these ladies like oh yeah yeah
and that's why they faking because
everybody been lying to about how good
your oral skills are and the truth is
your mouth ain't doing nothing for
nobody if you were to seduce me how
would you do it I wouldn't and I'm going
to take a shot cuz the thought of it
disgusts me I'm going to take a ginger
shot
yes good for her yep good for her
Kendall Jenner deserves better yep
Travis Scott's waiting at home yeah
don't be with this Dopey
[Music]
loser me I didn't want to answer that
either check you got it just just run
it I dare you to kiss me on the mouth I
think we both de um and that's the thing
about queerness is you're either best
friends or you move in together in a
week why do you why why what the [__] I
dare you to kiss me on the mouth with
tongue Cheers Cheers wait he didn't even
cheers me um I dare you to kiss me on
the mouth with tongue with tongue I
can't do with consent with consent let's
both take a shot okay let's both take a
shot without tongue is there a without
tongue without
Tong I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know this is fun I think
you're really cool he's like me but a
boy version I think his personality I
can tell like we can get along and be
really good like friends and [__] like
that you wouldn't kiss me on camera no
not on camera I feel that I'm I'm a
private person cool high five you're
going to high five
me not like a hand what you rather have
a handshake five I have a handshake
whatever take this
shot okay oh well nobody's
[__] that whole episode gave me
it anything else you want to say no all
right me
NE